my name is Michele Kaare and I'm a
professional cyclist for the BMW happy
tooth team and today I'm challenging
legendary stuntman Andy Bell and his
Ferrari to a race
I have no idea how the today is going to
go I'm going to just be chewing my
fingernails off if I'm sitting dead stop
on the 405 in this car 600 horsepower
just waiting to be used and going zero
miles an hour
and the reigning u23 national champion
for cycling and this year is my first
year riding as a professional today I'm
going to be riding some pretty sweet
equipment it's basically the Ferrari
equivalent for a bicycle I'm a
professional stuntman race car driver
race truck driver part-time daredevil
pretty much do it all
2011 Ferrari 458 Italia doesn't need
much explaining I don't think it's got
that yellow horsey on the front that
means it's pretty badass today's race is
very different from any normal cycling
race we will be battling regular Los
Angeles traffic we're gonna be taking
two different routes down from up here
the top of Topanga Canyon to Santa
Monica Pier but that is necessary
because bikes can't go on the highway
Telford Oh traffic up here
come on don't you know a racin
I remove the Ferrari
oh man
you beat me oh sure traffic yes yeah
obviously traffic how was your ride it
was great we hit about 40 miles an hour
going down the first ascent which was
super scary it was super fun kind of
like driving a Ferrari I think you had
me by what like six minutes or something
that was really close
accident and then like people getting in
my way and then red lights the exit here
in Santa Monica was terrible so can that
a not only did you win but you also got
fit and I just got fatter sitting in the
car maybe I could just get one of those
like baby things are you sitting yeah
yeah I could just like have a beer and
you could just tell me around okay okay
look at that next video re sticker on
the side thanks BuzzFeed good times